crowds of expectant family and friends
wait outside the gates of insane prison
in Yangon
after news of an unexpected amnesty
specifically for those charged under a
controversial article in myanmar's Penal
Code Banning fake news and incitement
against the military introduced after
the February 2021 Coupe
to the 153 prisoners both male and
female who are serving sentences under
article 505-a at prisons across the
country are on the amnesty list
eventually the gates opened and the
buses started to roll out anxiety and
excitement on the faces of those on
board few of these prisoners expected an
early release
was arrested in 2021 on the first day of
the silent strike on December 10th while
covering the news of the
photojournalists I was charged under
Section 505a and sentenced to three
years
my husband is national league for
democracy Minister for Yangon and I
don't expect he'll be released he's a
journalist and sentenced under 505 to
three years so I hope he will be set
free senior General Minong lies hosting
China's foreign minister in the capital
nepado some believe Beijing may be
encouraging the Junta to soften its
combative approach others think the
concessions are a result of sanctions
already in place economic sanctions that
deprive the hunter of the resources
required to operate its War making
machinery
would weaken its capacity to attack the
people of Myanmar
tens of thousands of political prisoners
remain in jail with little chance of
early release particularly aung San
tsuchi whose 33-year jail sentence could
take her to the end of her life Tony
Chang Al Jazeera